The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today's agenda
is to say a few more things
about continuous random
variables.
Mainly we're going to talk a
little bit about inference.
This is a topic that we're going
to revisit at the end of
the semester.
But there's a few things
that we can
already say at this point.
And then the new topic for
today is the subject of
derived distributions.
Basically if you know the
distribution of one random
variable, and you have a
function of that random
variable, how to find a
distribution for that function.
And it's a fairly mechanical
skill, but that's an important
one, so we're going
to go through it.
So let's see where we stand.
Here is the big picture.
That's all we have
done so far.
We have talked about discrete
random variables, which we
described by probability
mass function.
So if we have multiple random
variables, we describe them
with the a joint
mass function.
And then we define conditional
probabilities, or conditional
PMFs, and the three are related
according to this
formula, which is, you can
think of it either as the
definition of conditional
probability.
Or as the multiplication rule,
the probability of two things
happening is the product of the
probabilities of the first
thing happening, and then the
second happening, given that
the first has happened.
There's another relation between
this, which is the
probability of x occurring, is
the sum of the different
probabilities of the different
ways that x may occur, which
is in conjunction with different
values of y.
And there's an analog of all
that in the continuous world,
where all you do is to replace
p's by f's, and replace sums
by integrals.
So the formulas all
look the same.
The interpretations are a little
more subtle, so the f's
are not probabilities, they're
probability densities.
So they're probabilities per
unit length, or in the case of
joint PDf's, these are
probabilities per unit area.
So they're densities
of some sort.
Probably the more subtle concept
to understand what it
really is the conditional
density.
In some sense, it's simple.
It's just the density of X in
a world where you have been
told the value of the random
variable Y. It's a function
that has two arguments, but the
best way to think about it
is to say that we fixed y.
We're told the value of the
random variable Y, and we look
at it as a function of x.
So as a function of x, the
denominator is a constant, and
it just looks like the
joint density.
when we keep y fixed.
So it's really a function of
one argument, just the
argument x.
And it has the same shape as the
joint's density when you
take that slice of it.
So conditional PDFs are just
slices of joint PDFs.
There's a bunch of concepts,
expectations, variances,
cumulative distribution
functions that apply equally
well for to both universes
of discrete or
continuous random variables.
So why is probability useful?
Probability is useful because,
among other things, we use it
to make sense of the
world around us.
We use it to make inferences
about things that we do not
see directly.
And this is done in a
very simple manner
using the base rule.
We've already seen some of that,
and now we're going to
revisit it with a bunch of
different variations.
And the variations come because
sometimes our random
variable are discrete, sometimes
they're continuous,
or we can have a combination
of the two.
So the big picture is that
there's some unknown random
variable out of there, and we
know the distribution that's
random variable.
And in the discrete case, it's
going to be given by PMF.
In the continuous case,
it's given a PDF.
Then we have some phenomenon,
some noisy phenomenon or some
measuring device, and that
measuring device produces
observable random variables Y.
We don't know what x is, but we
have some beliefs about how
X is distributed.
We observe the random variable
Y. We need a
model of this box.
And the model of that box is
going to be either a PMF, for
the random variable Y. And that
model tells us, if the
true state of the world is X,
how do we expect to Y to be
distributed?
That's for the case where
Y is this discrete.
If Y is a continuous, you might
instead have a density
for Y, or something
of that form.
So in either case, this
should be a function
that's known to us.
This is our model of the
measuring device.
And now having observed
y, we want to make
inferences about x.
What does it mean to
make inferences?
Well the most complete answer in
the inference problem is to
tell me the probability
distribution
of the unknown quantity.
But when I say the probability
distribution, I
don't mean this one.
I mean the probability
distribution that takes into
account the measurements
that you got.
So the output of an inference
problem is to come up with the
distribution of X, the unknown
quantity, given what we have
already observed.
And in the discrete case, it
would be an object like that.
If X is continuous, it would
be an object of this kind.
OK, so we're given conditional
probabilities of this type,
and we want to get conditional
distributions of the opposite
type where the order of the
conditioning is being reversed.
So the starting point
is always a formula
such as this one.
The probability of x happening,
and then y
happening given that
x happens.
This is the probability that
a particular x and y happen
simultaneously.
But this is also equal to the
probability that y happens,
and then that x happens, given
that y has happened.
And you take this expression
and send one term to the
denominator of the other side,
and this gives us the base
rule for the discrete case.
Which is this one that you have
already seen, and you
have played with it.
So this is what the formula
looks like in
the discrete case.
And the typical example where
both random variables are
discrete is the one we discussed
some time ago.
X is, let's say, a binary
variable, or whether an
airplane is present
up there or not.
Y is a discrete measurement, for
example, whether our radar
beeped or it didn't beep.
And we make inferences and
calculate the probability that
the plane is there, or the
probability that the plane is
not there, given the measurement
that we have made.
And of course X and Y do not
need to be just binary.
They could be more general
discrete random variables.
So how does the story change
in the continuous case?
First, what's a possible
application of
the continuous case?
Well, think of X as being some
signal that takes values over
a continuous range.
Let's say X is the current
through a resistor.
And then you have some measuring
device that measures
currents, but that device is
noisy, it gets hit, let's say
for example, by Gaussian
noise.
And the Y that you observe is a
noisy version of X. But your
instruments are analog, so
you measure things on
a continuous scale.
What are you going to
do in that case?
Well the inference problem, the
output of the inference
problem, is going to be the
conditional distribution of X.
What do you think your current
is based on a particular value
of Y that you have observed?
So the output of our inference
problem is, given the specific
value of Y, to calculate this
entire function as a function
of x, and then go and plot it.
How do we calculate it?
You go through the same
calculation as in the discrete
case, except that all of the
x's gets replaced by p's.
In the continuous case, it's
equally true that the joint's
density is the product of the
marginal density with the
conditional density.
So the formula is still
valid with just a
little change of notation.
So we end up with the same
formula here, except that we
replace x's with p's.
So all of these functions
are known to us.
We have formulas for them.
We fix a specific value of y,
we plug it in, so we're left
with a function of x.
And that gives us the posterior
distribution.
Actually there's also a
denominator term that's not
necessarily given to us, but we
can always calculate it if
we have the marginal of X,
and we have the model for
measuring device.
Then we can always find the
marginal distribution of Y. So
this quantity, that number, is
in general a known one, as
well, and doesn't give
us any problems.
So to complicate things a little
bit, we can also look
into situations where our two
random variables are of
different kinds.
For example, one random variable
could be discrete,
and the other it might
be continuous.
And there's two versions.
Here one version is when X is
discrete, but Y is continuous.
What's an example of this?
Well suppose that I send a
single bit of information so
my X is 0 or 1.
And what I measure is Y,
which is X plus, let's
say, Gaussian noise.
This is the standard example
that shows up in any textbook
on communication, or
signal processing.
You send a single bit, but what
you observe is a noisy
version of that bit.
You start with a model
of your x's.
These would be your prior
probabilities.
For example, you might be
believe that either 0 or 1 are
equally likely, in which case
your PMF gives equal weight to
two possible values.
And then we need a model of
our measuring device.
This is one specific model.
The general model would have
a shape such as follows.
Y has a distribution,
its density.
And that density, however,
depends on the value of X.
So when x is 0, we might get
a density of this kind.
And when x is 1, we might
get the density
of a different kind.
So these are the conditional
densities of y in a universe
that's specified by a particular
value of x.
And then we go ahead and
do our inference.
OK, what's the right formula
for doing this inference?
We need a formula that's sort of
an analog of this one, but
applies to the case where we
have two random variables of
different kinds.
So let me just redo this
calculation here.
Except that I'm not going to
have a probability of taking
specific values.
It will have to be something
a little different.
So here's how it goes.
Let's look at the probability
that X takes a specific value
that makes sense in the discrete
case, but for the
continuous random variable,
let's look at the probability
that it takes values in
some little interval.
And now this probability of
two things happening, I'm
going to write it
as a product.
And I'm going to write
this as a product in
two different ways.
So one way is to say that this
is the probability that X
takes that value and then given
that X takes that value,
the probability that Y falls
inside that interval.
So this is our usual
multiplication rule for
multiplying probabilities, but
I can use the multiplication
rule also in a different way.
It's the probability
that Y falls in
the range of interest.
And then the probability that X
takes the value of interest
given that Y satisfies
the first condition.
So this is something that's
definitely true.
We're just using the
multiplication rule.
And now let's translate it
into PMF is PDF notation.
So the entry up there is the
PMF of X evaluated at x.
The second entry, what is it?
Well probabilities of
little intervals are
given to us by densities.
But we are in the conditional
universe where X takes on a
particular value.
So it's going to be the density
of Y given the value
of X times delta.
So probabilities of little
intervals are given by the
density times the length of
the little interval, but
because we're working in the
conditional universe, it has
to be the conditional density.
Now let's try the second
expression.
This is the probability
that the Y falls
into the little interval.
So that's the density
of Y times delta.
And then here we have an
object which is the
conditional probability X in a
universe where the value of Y
is given to us.
Now this relation is sort
of approximate.
This is true for very small
delta in the limit.
But we can cancel the deltas
from both sides, and we're
left with a formula that links
together PMFs and PDFs.
Now this may look terribly
confusing because there's both
p's and f's involved.
But the logic should be clear.
If a random variable
is discrete, it's
described by PMF.
So here we're talking about
the PMF of X in some
particular universe.
X is discrete, so
it has a PMF.
Similarly here.
Y is continuous so it's
described by a PDF.
And even in the conditional
universe where I tell you the
value of X, Y is still a
continuous random variable, so
it's been described by a PDF.
So this is the basic
relation that links
together PMF and PDFs.
In this mixed the world.
And now in this inequality,
you can take this term and
send it to the new denominator
to the other side.
And what you end up with
is the formula
that we have up here.
And this is a formula that we
can use to make inferences
about the discrete random
variable X when we're told the
value of the continuous random
variable Y. The probability
that X takes on a particular
value has something
to do with the prior.
And other than that, it's
proportional to this quantity,
the conditional of Y given X.
So these are the quantities
that we plotted here.
Suppose that the x's are equally
likely in your prior,
so we don't really care
about that term.
It tells us that the posterior
of X is proportional to that
particular density under
the given x's.
So in this picture, if I were to
get a particular y here, I
would say that x equals 1
has a probability that's
proportional to this quantity.
x equals 0 has a probability
that's
proportional to this quantity.
So the ratio of these two
quantities gives us the
relative odds of the different
x's given the y
that we have observed.
So we're going to come back to
this topic and redo plenty of
examples of these kinds towards
the end of the class,
when we spend some
time dedicated
to inference problems.
But already at this stage, we
sort of have the basic skills
to deal with a lot of that.
And it's useful at this
point to pull all
the formulas together.
So finally let's look at the
last case that's remaining.
Here we have a continuous
phenomenon that we're trying
to measure, but our measurements
are discrete.
What's an example where
this might happen?
So you have some device that
emits light, and you drive it
with a current that has
a certain intensity.
You don't know what that
current is, and it's a
continuous random variable.
But the device emits
light by sending
out individual photons.
And your measurement is some
other device that counts how
many photons did you get
in a single second.
So if we have devices that emit
a very low intensity you
can actually start counting
individual photons as they're
being observed.
So we have a discrete
measurement, which is the
number of problems, and we
have a continuous hidden
random variable that we're
trying to estimate.
What do we do in this case?
Well we start again with a
formula of this kind, and send
the p term to the denominator.
And that's the formula that we
use there, except that the
roles of x's and y's
are interchanged.
So since here we have Y being
discrete, we should change all
the subscripts.
It would be p_Y f_X given
y f_X, and P(Y given X).
So just change all
those subscripts.
Because now what we're used to
be continuous became discrete,
and vice versa.
Take that formula, send
the other terms to the
denominator, and we have a
formula for the density, or X,
given the particular
measurements for Y that we
have obtained.
In some sense that's all there
is in Bayesian inference.
It's using these very simple
one line formulas.
But why are there people then
who make their living solving
inference problems?
Well, the devil is
in the details.
As we're going to discuss,
there are some real world
issues of how exactly do you
design your f's, how do you
model your system, then how do
you do your calculations.
This might not be always easy.
For example, there's certain
integrals or sums that have to
be evaluated, which may be
hard to do and so on.
So this object is
a lot of richer
than just these formulas.
On the other hand, at the
conceptual level, that's the
basis for Bayesian inference,
that these
are the basic concepts.
All right, so now let's change
gear and move to the new
subject, which is the topic of
finding the distribution of a
functional for a random
variable.
We call those distributions
derived distributions, because
we're given the distribution
of X. We're interested in a
function of X. We want to derive
the distribution of
that function based on
the distribution
that we already know.
So it could be a function of
just one random variable.
It could be a function of
several random variables.
So one example that we are going
to solve at some point,
let's say you have to run the
variables X and Y. Somebody
tells you their distribution,
for example, is a uniform of
the square.
For some reason, you're
interested in the ratio of
these two random variables,
and you want to find the
distribution of that ratio.
You can think of lots of cases
where your random variable of
interest is created by taking
some other unknown variables
and taking a function of them.
And so it's legitimate to care
about the distribution of that
random variable.
A caveat, however.
There's an important case where
you don't need to find
the distribution of that
random variable.
And this is when you want to
calculate the expectations.
If all you care about is the
expected value of this
function of the random
variables, you can work
directly with the distribution
of the original random
variables without ever having
to find the PDF of g.
So you don't do unnecessary work
if it's not needed, but
if it's needed, or if you're
asked to do it,
then you just do it.
So how do we find the
distribution of the function?
As a warm-up, let's look
at the discrete case.
Suppose that X is a discrete
random variable and takes
certain values.
We have a function g that
maps x's into y's.
And we want to find the
probability mass function for
Y.
So for example, if I'm
interested in finding the
probability that Y takes on
this particular value, how
would they find it?
Well I ask, what are the
different ways that these
particular y value can happen?
And the different ways that it
can happen is either if x
takes this value, or if
X takes that value.
So we identify this event in the
y space with that event in
the x space.
These two events
are identical.
X falls in this set if and only
if Y falls in that set.
Therefore, the probability of
Y falling in that set is the
probability of X falling
in that set.
The probability of X falling in
that set is just the sum of
the individual probabilities
of the x's in this set.
So we just add the probabilities
of the different
x's where the summation is taken
over all x's that leads
to that particular value of y.
Very good.
So that's all there is
in the discrete case.
It's a very nice and simple.
So let's transfer
these methods to
the continuous case.
Suppose we are in the
continuous case.
Suppose that X and Y now can
take values anywhere.
And I try to use same methods
and I ask, what is the
probability that Y is going
to take this value?
At least if the diagram is this
way, you would say this
is the same as the probability
that X takes this value.
So I can find the probability
of Y being this in terms of
the probability of
X being that.
Is this useful?
In the continuous
case, it's not.
Because in the continuous case,
any single value has 0
probability.
So what you're going to get out
of this argument is that
the probability Y takes this
value is 0, is equal to the
probability that X takes that
value which also 0.
That doesn't help us.
We want to do something more.
We want to actually find,
perhaps, the density of Y, as
opposed to the probabilities
of individual y's.
So to find the density of Y,
you might argue as follows.
I'm looking at an interval for
y, and I ask what's the
probability of falling
in this interval.
And you go back and find the
corresponding set of x's that
leads to those y's, and equate
those two probabilities.
The probability of all of those
y's collectively should
be equal to the probability of
all of the x's that map into
that interval collectively.
And this way you can
relate the two.
As far as the mechanics go, in
many cases it's easier to not
to work with little intervals,
but instead to work with
cumulative distribution
functions that used to work
with sort of big intervals.
So you can instead do
a different picture.
Look at this set of y's.
This is the set of y's
that are smaller
than a certain value.
The probability of this set
is given by the cumulative
distribution of the
random variable Y.
Now this set of y's gets
produced by some corresponding
set of x's.
Maybe these are the x's that
map into y's in that set.
And then we argue as follows.
The probability that the Y falls
in this interval is the
same as the probability that
X falls in that interval.
So the event of Y falling here
and the event of X falling
there are the same, so their
probabilities must be equal.
And then I do the calculations
here.
And I end up getting the
cumulative distribution
function of Y. Once I have the
cumulative, I can get the
density by just differentiating.
So this is the general cookbook
procedure that we
will be using to calculate
it derived distributions.
We're interested in a random
variable Y, which is a
function of the x's.
We will aim at obtaining the
cumulative distribution of Y.
Somehow, manage to calculate the
probability of this event.
Once we get it, and what I mean
by get it, I don't mean
getting it for a single
value of little y.
You need to get this
for all little y's.
So you need to get the
function itself, the
cumulative distribution.
Once you get it in that form,
then you can calculate the
derivative at any particular
point.
And this is going to give
you the density of Y.
So a simple two-step
procedure.
The devil is in the details of
how you carry the mechanics.
So let's do one first example.
Suppose that X is a uniform
random variable, takes values
between 0 and 2.
We're interested in the random
variable Y, which is the cube
of X. What kind of distribution
is it going to have?
Now first notice that Y takes
values between 0 and 8.
So X is uniform, so all the
x's are equally likely.
You might then say, well, in
that case, all the y's should
be equally likely.
So Y might also have a
uniform distribution.
Is this true?
We'll find out.
So let's start applying the
cookbook procedure.
We want to find first the
cumulative distribution of the
random variable Y, which by
definition is the probability
that the random variable is
less than or equal to a
certain number.
That's what we want to find.
What we have in our hands is the
distribution of X. That's
what we need to work with.
So the first step that you need
to do is to look at this
events and translate it, and
write it in terms of the
random variable about which you
know you have information.
So Y is X cubed, so this event
is the same as that event.
So now we can forget
about the y's.
It's just an exercise involving
a single random
variable with a known
distribution and we want to
calculate the probability
of some event.
So we're looking
at this event.
X cubed being less than or equal
to Y. We massage that
expression so that's it involves
X directly, so let's
take cubic roots of both sides
of this inequality.
This event is the same as the
event that X is less than or
equal to Y to the 1/3.
Now with a uniform distribution
on [0,2], what is
that probability going to be?
It's the probability of being in
the interval from 0 to y to
the 1/3, so it's going to be in
the area under the uniform
going up to that point.
And what's the area under
that uniform?
So here's x.
Here is the distribution
of X. It goes up to 2.
The distribution of
X is this one.
We want to go up to
y to the 1/3.
So the probability for this
event happening is this area.
And the area is equal to the
base, which is y to the 1/3
times the height.
What is the height?
Well since the density must
integrate to 1, the total area
under the curve has to be 1.
So the height here is 1/2, and
that explains why we get the
1/2 factor down there.
So that's the formula for the
cumulative distribution.
And then the rest is easy.
You just take derivatives.
You differentiate this
expression with respect to y
1/2 times 1/3, and y
drops by one power.
So you get y to 2/3 in
the denominator.
So if you wish to plot this,
it's 1/y to the 2/3.
So when y goes to 0, it sort
of blows up and it
goes on this way.
Is this picture correct
the way I've drawn it?
What's wrong with it?
[? AUDIENCE:  Something. ?]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
y only takes values
from 0 to 8.
This formula that I wrote here
is only correct when the
preview picture applies.
I took my y to the 1/3 to
be between 0 and 2.
So this formula here is only
correct for y between 0 and 8.
And for that reason, the formula
for the derivative is
also true only for a
y between 0 and 8.
And any other values of why are
impossible, so they get
zero density.
So to complete the picture
here, the PDF of y has a
cut-off of 8, and it's also
0 everywhere else.
And one thing that we see is
that the distribution of Y is
not uniform.
Certain y's are more likely than
others, even though we
started with a uniform random
variable X. All right.
So we will keep doing examples
of this kind, a sequence of
progressively more interesting
or more complicated.
So that's going to continue
in the next lecture.
You're going to see plenty of
examples in your recitations
and tutorials and so on.
So let's do one that's pretty
similar to the one that we
did, but it's going to add to
just a small twist in how we
do the mechanics.
OK so you set your
cruise control
when you start driving.
And you keep driving at the
constants based at the
constant speed.
Where you set your cruise
control is somewhere
between 30 and 60.
You're going to drive
a distance of 200.
And so the time it's going to
take for your trip is 200 over
the setting of your
cruise control.
So it's 200/V.
Somebody gives you the
distribution of V, and they
tell you not only it's between
30 and 60, it's roughly
equally likely to be anything
between 30 and 60, so we have
a uniform distribution
over that range.
So we have a distribution of
V. We want to find the
distribution of the random
variable T, which is the time
it takes till your trip ends.
So how are we going
to proceed?
We'll use the exact same
cookbook procedure.
We're going to start by
finding the cumulative
distribution of T.
What is this?
By definition, the cumulative
distribution is the
probability that T is less
than a certain number.
OK.
Now we don't know the
distribution of T, so we
cannot to work with these
event directly.
But we take that event and
translate it into T-space.
So we replace the t's by what we
know T to be in terms of V
or
the v's All right.
So we have the distribution
of V. So now let's
calculate this quantity.
OK.
Let's massage this event and
rewrite it as the probability
that V is larger or
equal to 200/T.
So what is this going to be?
So let's say that 200/T
is some number that
falls inside the range.
So that's going to be true if
200/T is bigger than 30, and
less than 60.
Which means that t is
less than 30/200.
No, 200/30.
And bigger than 200/60.
So for t's inside that range,
this number 200/t falls inside
that range.
This is the range of t's that
are possible, given the
description of the problem
the we have set up.
So for t's in that range, what
is the probability that V is
bigger than this number?
So V being bigger than that
number is the probability of
this event, so it's going to be
the area under this curve.
So the area under that curve
is the height of the curve,
which is 1/3 over 30
times the base.
How big is the base?
Well it's from that point to 60,
so the base has a length
of 60 minus 200/t.
And this is a formula which is
valid for those t's for which
this picture is correct.
And this picture is correct if
200/T happens to fall in this
interval, which is the same as
T falling in that interval,
which are the t's that
are possible.
So finally let's find the
density of T, which is what
we're looking for.
We find this by taking the
derivative in this expression
with respect to t.
We only get one term
from here.
And this is going to be 200/30,
1 over t squared.
And this is the formula for
the density for t's in the
allowed to range.
OK, so that's the end of the
solution to this particular
problem as well.
I said that there was a little
twist compared to
the previous one.
What was the twist?
Well the twist was that in the
previous problem we dealt with
the X cubed function, which was
monotonically increasing.
Here we dealt with the
function that was
monotonically decreasing.
So when we had to find the
probability that T is less
than something, that translated
into an event that
V was bigger than something.
Your time is less than something
if and only if your
velocity is bigger
than something.
So for when you're dealing
with the monotonically
decreasing function, at some
point some inequalities will
have to get reversed.
Finally let's look at
a very useful one.
Which is the case where we take
a linear function of a
random variable.
So X is a random variable with
given distribution, and we can
see there is a linear
function.
So in this particular instance,
we take a to be
equal to 2 and b equal to 5.
And let us first argue
just by picture.
So X is a random variable that
has a given distribution.
Let's say it's this
weird shape here.
And x ranges from -1 to +2.
Let's do things one
step at the time.
Let's first find the
distribution of 2X.
Why do you think you
know about 2X?
Well if x ranges from -1 to 2,
then the random variable X is
going to range from -2 to +4.
So that's what the range
is going to be.
Now dealing with the random
variable 2X, as opposed to the
random variable X, in some sense
it's just changing the
units in which we measure
that random variable.
It's just changing the
scale on which we
draw and plot things.
So if it's just a scale change,
then intuition should
tell you that the random
variable X should have a PDF
of the same shape, except that
it's scaled out by a factor of
2, because our random variable
of 2X now has a range that's
twice as large.
So we take the same PDF and
scale it up by stretching the
x-axis by a factor of 2.
So what does scaling
correspond to
in terms of a formula?
So the distribution of 2X as a
function, let's say, a generic
argument z, is going to be the
distribution of X, but scaled
by a factor of 2.
So taking a function and
replacing its arguments by the
argument over 2, what it
does is it stretches it
by a factor of 2.
You have probably been tortured
ever since middle
school to figure out when need
to stretch a function, whether
you need to put 2z or z/2.
And the one that actually does
the stretching is to put the
z/2 in that place.
So that's what the
stretching does.
Could that to be the
full answer?
Well there's a catch.
If you stretch this function by
a factor of 2, what happens
to the area under
the function?
It's going to get doubled.
But the total probability must
add up to 1, so we need to do
something else to make sure that
the area under the curve
stays to 1.
So we need to take that function
and scale it down by
this factor of 2.
So when you're dealing with a
multiple of a random variable,
what happens to the PDF is you
stretch it according to the
multiple, and then scale it
down by the same number so
that you preserve the area
under that curve.
So now we found the distribution
of 2X.
How about the distribution
of 2X + 5?
Well what does adding 5
to random variable do?
You're going to get essentially
the same values
with the same probability,
except that those values all
get shifted by 5.
So all that you need to do is
to take this PDF here, and
shift it by 5 units.
So the range used to
be from -2 to 4.
The new range is going
to be from 3 to 9.
And that's the final answer.
This is the distribution of
2X + 5, starting with this
particular distribution of X.
Now shifting to the
right by b, what
does it do to a function?
Shifting to the right to
by a certain amount,
mathematically, it corresponds
to putting -b in the argument
of the function.
So I'm taking the formula that
I had here, which is the
scaling by a factor of a.
The scaling down to keep the
total area equal to 1.
And then I need to introduce
this extra
term to do the shifting.
So this is a plausible
argument.
The proof by picture that this
should be the right answer.
But just in order to keep our
skills tuned and refined, let
us do this derivation in a
more formal way using our
two-step cookbook procedure.
And I'm going to do it under
the assumption that a is
positive, as in the example
that's we just did.
So what's the two-step
procedure?
We want to find the cumulative
of Y, and after that we're
going to differentiate.
By definition the cumulative
is the probability that the
random variable takes values
less than a certain number.
And now we need to take this
event and translate it, and
express it in terms of the
original random variables.
So Y is, by definition,
aX + b, so we're
looking at this event.
And now we want to express this
event in a clean form
where X shows up in
a straight way.
Let's say I'm going to massage
this event and
write it in this form.
For this inequality to be true,
x should be less than or
equal to (y minus
b) divided by a.
OK, now what is this?
This is the cumulative
distribution of X evaluated at
the particular point.
So we got a formula for the
cumulative Y based on the
cumulative of X. What's
the next step?
Next step is to take derivatives
of both sides.
So the density of Y is going to
be the derivative of this
expression with respect to y.
OK, so now here we need
to use the chain rule.
It's going to be the derivative
of the F function
with respect to its argument.
And then we need to take the
derivative of the argument
with respect to y.
What is the derivative
of the cumulative?
The derivative of
the cumulative
is the density itself.
And we evaluate it at the
point of interest.
And then the chain rule tells
us that we need to take the
derivative of this with
respect to y, and the
respect to y is 1/a.
And this gives us the formula
which is consistent with what
I had written down here,
for the case where a
is a positive number.
What if a was a negative
number?
Could this formula be true?
Of course not.
Densities cannot be
negative, right?
So that formula cannot
be true.
Something needs to change.
What should change?
Where does this argument break
down when a is negative?
So when I write this inequality
in this form, I
divide by a.
But when you divide by a
negative number, the direction
of an inequality is
going to change.
So when a is negative, this
inequality becomes larger than
or equal to.
And in that case, the expression
that I have up
there would change when this
is larger than here.
Instead of getting the
cumulative, I would get 1
minus the cumulative of (y
minus b) divided by a.
So this is the probability that
X is bigger than this
particular number.
And now when you take the
derivatives, there's going to
be a minus sign that shows up.
And that minus sign will
end up being here.
And so we're taking the negative
of a negative number,
and that basically is equivalent
to taking the
absolute value of that number.
So all that happens when we have
a negative a is that we
have to take the absolute value
of the scaling factor
instead of the factor itself.
All right, so this general
formula is quite useful for
dealing with linear functions
of random variables.
And one nice application of it
is to take the formula for a
normal random variable, consider
a linear function of
a normal random variable, plug
into this formula, and what
you will find is that Y also
has a normal distribution.
So using this formula, now we
can prove a statement that I
had made a couple of lectures
ago, that a linear function of
a normal random variable
is also linear.
That's how you would prove it.
I think this is it
for today so.